[Musique]
l'autonomie c'est tout ce qu'on peut
mettre en place dans les politiques
publiques politiques locales pour faire
en sorte que les personnes puissent agir
selon leur choix
malgré une perte d'autonomie parfois un
handicap ou un accident de la vie car en
sorte que la vie sain climat plutôt à la
personne que l' inverse
moi c'est ça l'autonomie c'est pouvoir
être guidé par vos propres choix
quelle que soit la situation la
dépendance c'est évidemment le moment où
cette autonomie et perdu voire parfois
définitivement
et là pour le coup il faut aussi qu'on
ait les structures adaptées pour
accompagner cette dépendance faire en
sorte que les choses viennent à vous et
pas l'inversé
aujourd'hui on est dans un virage
démographique très important et nous
devons tous avoir l'esprit ce n'est pas
un problème qui va arriver dans 20 ou 30
ans mais bien dans 10 ans et à peine dix
ans même dans cinq ans on aura
énormément besoin d'avoir réfléchi bien
en amont pour accueillir toutes les
personnes âgées de 75 à 85 ans qui
arrive là inéluctablement
donc il faut qu'on adapte à la fois le
domicile pour que les personnes puissent
rester chez elles aussi longtemps que
possible qu'on puisse aussi réfléchir à
des dispositifs comme on a vu
aujourd'hui d'habitat partagé de
colocation qui ne sont pas les solutions
uniques ya énormément de solutions
diverses et variées pour faire en sorte
que les personnes donc reste à domicile
ensuite faire en sorte que les
établissements qui accueillent des
personnes plus dépendantes
parce que la vie a fait qu'elles sont
plus dépendantes aujourd'hui et bien
soit mieux armé pour le faire plus
ouvert aussi vers l'extérieur faire en
sorte que tout ça s'articule et ne soit
pas cloisonnés ça demande aussi une
réflexion des collectivités locales elle
même parce qu'il faut qu'elle
réfléchisse au fait que ces personnes
doivent être intégrés dans leur centre
ville dans leur centre bourg pour que
tout ça s'articule bien et que les
personnes gardent leur place jusqu'au
bout dans la société
on ne part pas d'une feuille blanche
comme vous le savez on parle de rapports
divers et de travail parlementaire aussi
depuis deux ans nous nous sommes attelés
bien sûr à la tâche dès le départ
aujourd'hui on est quasiment dans
l'opérationnel une dernière concertation
qu'on doit avoir entre financeurs et
puis aussi pour ne pas avoir une idée
plaquer mais une idée co-construite
maintenant de ce que peut faire de cette
belle loi autonomie qui ne doit pas être
réduite seulement à trouver des
dispositifs différents mais on doit
travailler à la fois sont les métiers
sur l'habitat comme vous l'avez vue sur
toute l' approche domiciliaire sur les
établissements qui doit se reconvertir
un peu et puis aussi sur la personne
parce qu'il parle peu souvent de la
personne qui doit redevenir le centre du
dispositif